&gt;&gt; It looks like two numbers convey a lot of information. In algebra we use a
similar system to identify locations. This is system is called the coordinate
plane or the Cartesian plane. The system uses two lines known as the x axis and
the y axis. The x axis is the horizontal line and the y axis is the vertical
line that runs through plane. By drawing this graph we can create an infinite
world of numbers and intersections. Where the x axis and y axis intersect is
called the origin, the center. Just like we labelled streets and avenues on our
maps, we can label our axes with numbers, 0, 1, 2, and so on. We can do this in
the horizontal direction and in the vertical direction. To indicate a point on
this Cartesian system, how many numbers would we need to specify? This can be
tricky, so think back to our map. How many numbers would we need to specify a
point like this? I'm not asking you for the location, I'm asking you for the
number of points. Put your answer in this box.